[Musique]
voilà comment commence une journée
diplomatique
les deux collectivités et l'état se
retrouvent pour parler d'une même voix
celle de la réunion france et l'avant
logiciel
les dernières discussions les derniers
calages avec l'ensemble des partenaires
il faut qu'on sente que la france la
réunion ensemble c'est la réunion
unifrance réunion réunion france unie
d'une manière générale sur l'implication
des collectivités territoriales de la
réunion dans la coopération régionale
par principe c'est évidemment une
excellente chose parce que sinon
seraient pas de sens il est membre d'une
organisation régionale pourrait à
travers le département de la réunion six
départements lui même sens large où la
région et il n'était pas impliqué dans
ces actions de coopération régionale et
en plus je trouve enfin je constate avec
avec satisfaction que l on des actions
complémentaires
chacune dans ses domaines de compétence
et d'activité particuliers et donc les
deux sont actives dynamiques en
propositions en initiatives et c'est
très bien comme ça
l'essentiel c'est d'arriver à faire une
bonne coordination de ce que fait l'état
de ce que fait la région de ce que fait
département l'entrée de la délégation
française dans la salle du 33e conseil
des ministres de la commission de
l'océan indien donne de suite la
dimension de cette institution de cinq
états membres
26 millions d'habitants la 10e
organisations internationales
partenaires les attentions qui va
assurer un seul billet à saas-fee volée
du gauche
seize représentants de la délégation
réunionnaise avec daniel gonthier vice
président du département et l'état
didier robert croit dans cette
communauté de destin ne réussirons que
si nous nous appréhendons donc notre
positionnement dans cet espace avec
l'afrique d'une part le lan et l'asie
d'autres changements de configuration et
début des travaux pour la commission et
parmi les intervenants la francophonie
est un point commun des changes
elle nous unie dans la diversité dans le
respect des diversités dans le respect
des spécificités de chacun et cette
région prova souhait que nous avons eu
raison en francophonie de porter la
convention sur la diversité des
expressions culturelles à l'unesco
la carte que ça c'est vrai quand on
parle francophonie on parle aussi l'âme
à l'encré holt est exact c'est ça qu'on
veut faire partager à hauteur je vous en
remercie de cette ouverture d'esprit
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça la
modernité de la france
un travail diplomatique de fonds
essentiels sur des dossiers de fond tels
que la sécurité la santé publique la
préservation des ressources naturelles
la culture et enfin les progrès
économiques de nos plateformes qui a
joué son rôle au niveau de l'économie
bleus au niveau de la sécurité maritime
même que les gens ne savent pas notre
problème de faire savoir aux gens ce que
nous sommes ce que nous faisons et
comment eux qui sont partis prenants ils
sont ils sont les gagnants parmi les
intervenants incontournable l'union
européenne premier partenaire financier
et technique de la coi 16 ans entrée
stratégique à des commerces
l union européenne et les pays d'afrique
l'europe la chine citant de pays
s'intéressent à cette zone c'est qu'elle
a clairement une richesse mais seule la
coopération peut aider à veiller sur les
5,5 millions du jeune économique
exclusive de ces îles de l'océan indien
[Musique]